today's wildflowers are charvi jessica
and angelina from dallas texas
these girls made headlines when they
came up with a virtual
tutoring program called tutor scope
the non-profit helps kids and their
parents
keep up with the school work during the
pandemic i'd love to welcome them
charvi jessica angelina are you there
okay tell us about tutor
so we started tutorscope back in march
of 2020
when the pandemic was starting and um
schools were beginning to go virtual
and with that it became apparent that
student-to-teacher interactions would be
affected because
you can't really just walk up to a
teacher's desk to ask them a question um
in a virtual setting
so i thought what if we could have
student tutors
teaching other students virtually so i
asked angelina and jessica to join me
and they were so excited within two
weeks we had our entire website and
system up and running for
students to actually um start getting
tutored
and now we have over 22 tutors
that are spread out all across the
united states including ohio
texas and even arizona
i mean this is amazing i have to ask the
next question which is
do you think that the psychology of also
young people
seeing other young people because here's
me in home school
um it literally and my kids don't look
at me
like the teacher you know i'm their
parent and
you know do you think that that am i the
only parent that feels this way
do kids feel this way is there a kid
adult dynamic what do you think
there's definitely this component of us
being closer to the curriculum
um so kids are able to just like kind of
connect with us a little more
it's just very stressful right now for
everyone
and so um we kind of also just help with
the workload and the stress that parents
have right now
and then also um like decreasing the
amount of frustration that can be
happening with like
having to become the teachers during
this time because that's
that's just a new thing for a lot of
parents jessica
how do you feel about teaching kids you
can do it in your own state or
other states can sign up to learn with
you guys right
yeah exactly we'll tutor any kid no
matter
what city or state they're in and really
our main objective ever since
we founded this organization was to have
everything
be completely free of cost to the
student so
that has definitely allowed us to be
accessible to a lot of kids
we've had about 250 students with us and
you know over 500 have registered
um so and they're all you know from
elementary school to high school
so it's been a really great experience
and angelina
like what's next for your non-profit do
you plan on expanding
everybody's like coming from even other
countries what's the plan yes
of course of course um well like you've
already mentioned
we've actually been getting application
from countries like canada india or even
russia
and we hope to continue creating a
bigger impact on a global scale to every
child in need
angelina do you ever see parents like me
on the floor
like just flipped out yeah i mean
we see you know first-hand parents and
everyone in general they're just
so stressed because of all the changes
that we've had to go through
so we um hope to you know we read
parents of that stress as well i can't
thank you enough
i mean this is so hard this really is
do you feel like you are connecting with
these younger people
and really bringing like alleviation
of all this stress yeah that's
definitely what we're hoping to
accomplish you know
i mean as angelina was saying this
pandemic has just brought on
so many new changes and stresses and
um what our goal is is to kind of just
create that student-to-student
interaction
that you'd normally get in school so you
know before
we study for upcoming tests during lunch
and things like that
so we just really kind of want to create
that same dynamic and same environment
with tudor scope
i can't thank you enough as a parent
for all adults out there you know i
think that kids are going to
see you and actually
honestly behave themselves a little bit
better and trust in the process
a little bit more thank you no thank you
thank you
actually and i just want to donate five
thousand dollars
to you guys and your organization and
your company
just to spend on whatever way you see
fit for
the growth and development of the tudor
scope program because
honestly and i'm gonna match it with
another five thousand so that's ten
thousand
to you guys thank you so much oh my god
thank you so much
you all deserve cake so much worse
so welcome you all deserve capes go out
there and fly and save
us thank you charvey jessica
and angelina tutor scope visit our
website for more information and how
you can sign up for tudor scope
you